foreign
is
this is the village of rho chai located
high in the mountains of vietnam
central plateau it is part of the dalot
area
to this relocation village come the
vietnamese mountain dwellers known as
mountain yards
a civic action program is underway here
to improve the health and well-being of
these primitive people
these films taken on 11 december 1965
show a friendly visit to the village by
a signal group chaplain and two civilian
missionaries
for the chaplain this is a regular part
of his routine
he visits the tribes in the dalot area
quite frequently
delivering simple sermons and
distributing small gifts
the grown-ups of the village look
forward to these visits as much as the
children
the mountain yards undernourished and in
poor health when first brought to this
relocation village
are steadily improving under the civic
action program
members of the 502nd battalion 101st
airborne division are briefed at a
command post outside of ben cott
it is 9 december 1965 and word has been
received
that vietcong forces are entrenched on a
big rubber plantation
some five miles to the west
the mission of the 502nd is to conduct
an assault landing by helicopter
and sweep the plantation for any hostile
units positioned there
arriving at the plantation the men of
the 502nd are joined by local friendly
natives
who act as their guides
the informants point out the carefully
screened hiding places of the vietcong
gorillas
dugouts and tunnels are scoured for
enemy personnel
but only a few items such as this
propaganda poster are found
throughout the plantation area troops
are deployed in patrols
searching fields roadside ditches and
thick patches of woods
the viet cong are nowhere to be found
however
and the search goes on hour after hour
at a shallow river ford some of the men
load up with jerry cans of fresh water
it will have to be boiled to purify it
and then cooled before use
armed guards cover the jeep crews
down the road to the east land mines
were discovered when one blew up
killing some of the airborne infantrymen
clearing work
started immediately
meanwhile some of the sweep teams take a
few minutes out for a water break
the plantation though a scant 25 miles
from saigon
is located in the famous d zone seen of
some of the toughest vietcong resistance
of the war
radio contact with search teams in the
area
reveals the same story as before still
no enemy forces cited
additional troops arrived to broaden the
scope of the mission
and with them the battalion chaplain who
drove up in his jeep
and prepared to conduct services for the
men
even with their small field altar out in
the open
these clergymen are a great comfort to
the fighting men
through the courageous service of these
chaplains the combat soldier remains
strong in spirit
and resolute in his duty
with operations now in full swing the
flying infantrymen move up
in force and fan out to search more
deeply the surrounding terrain
some light enemy sniper fire is
encountered and
mortar fire is directed at the suspected
vietcong positions
contact with the vc is not established
however
and finally the mission is called off
the first cavalry division air mobile is
implementing the air mobility concept in
vietnam
and these films of the division were
made from 9 through 11 december 1965.
at on k the first air cav has
established a highly complex
and sophisticated base of operations
embracing not only air operations
but major maintenance of all organic
helicopters
this includes tactical aircraft as well
as support copters
leading elements of this division first
arrived in vietnam on 15 september
1965 and proceeded to on k
this base and all of its facilities have
been developed in this wilderness area
since that time
last summer on the first of july 1965
the first cavalry division was
designated the first air mobile division
in the united states army
here in vietnam the division is a mighty
busy outfit
the maintenance work on aircraft is
carried out on the flight line
in tent covered conex containers
converted into shops
and on rollaway engine stands outdoors
aircraft upkeep and testing is constant
day after day to make sure the fleets of
choppers are operational at all times
the work being done encompasses not only
normal maintenance
but repairs to the assault helicopters
which have been damaged by viet cong
ground fire
the most delicate work for the aircraft
mechanics
is that which must be done on the rotors
of the helicopters
minute adjustments of bearing assemblies
and pitch adjustment
along with other critical maintenance is
carried out in the tent covered shops
this is to keep stray particles of dirt
and other foreign matter
from blowing onto exposed vital parts
out in front of the engine and
powertrain shop
two men of the 229th maintenance
battalion
install a hot end on a uh-1d
engine
in addition to the b level maintenance
carried out here in the shop
area line mechanics handle regular
servicing out on the flight line
to support this maintenance work there
is a parts supply depot near the shops
but the sprawling first air calf base
encompasses much more than the
maintenance facility for helicopters
and the overall installation continues
to grow
these men are pouring cement for a new
mess hall floor
in other localities around the base more
new buildings are being erected
the complex already includes
administrative buildings
communications air ops and several other
structures
a large pol dump supplies fuel and oil
for the aircraft
this is the airfield at once
it is the home of the division
helicopters and has become known to
airmen all over vietnam
as the golf course a multi-purpose field
it is capable of handling aircraft as
large as the air
force c-130s and it is not uncommon
to see a dozen or more helicopters
taking off at one time
the uh-1d helicopter is one of the most
versatile choppers
the first air calf has the workhorse of
the cargo copters
is the big ch-47 chinook which is used
to deliver everything from
troops to field artillery and there are
the smaller helicopters used in recon
work and air evacuation of the wounded
everywhere you look helicopters spill
the landing pads or the air over them
the business of the first air cavalry
division is
air mobility and that means total air
delivery
of everything required by the fighting
men of this division
whatever the airlift requirement of the
mission may be
there are combat-ready troops and
machines here to fulfill that
requirement
getting away from the airfield for the
moment there are still
other areas of the base to be seen
in the division headquarters area a
military museum
has been set up
on display here are various types of
weapons captured from the vietcong
during heliborn assaults upon enemy
forces
by the flying cavalrymen the communist
made recoilless rifles and other pieces
attest to the success of those past
airborne missions
conventional fixed-wing aircraft such as
the
cv2 caribou are also used by the
division
for a number of other chores requiring
more speed
than is available with the helicopters
all in all the control tower personnel
here
see nearly as much daily air traffic as
the control towers of many big u.s city
airports back in the states
to the on k airfield come all kinds of
airborne cargos
when this film was made the christmas
mail for the men of the division was
pouring in by the plane load
but the big c-130s of the air force and
the cargo carriers of the first
air cavalry division bring in every
conceivable item of material
from vehicles and aircraft parts to
containers of aircraft
fuel and office supplies everything
and anything that is needed for daily
routine
as well as tactical materiel for air
assault missions
to handle these heavy loads the runways
and parking strips were surfaced
with weatherproof heavy aluminum mats
one of the most interesting helicopters
in service with the division
is the sikorsky ch-54a flying crane
it was designed to airlift the heaviest
materiel
and offers a variety of cargo handling
accessories
on this particular mission a damaged
caribou aircraft is being transported
from on k airfield to the fixed wing
aircraft repair shops at quinon
the caribou's wings and parts of the
empanadas are being carried in the cargo
pod
of the cameraman's flying crane
while the caribou fuselage is being
delivered by one flying crane
the other is touching down with the rest
of the caribou parts
waiting ground crews move in and the
unloading begins at once
this mission is typical of the daily
routine
for the big helicrains and as a matter
of fact
the flight crew had barely completed
this delivery before they were given a
new assignment
an ad6 skyraider had crashed while
making an approach at some airfield
and it now had to be airlifted out to a
navy lst
in the harbor which would carry it to da
nang for repairs
and so the lift hook is made secure and
locked
and the cargo is ready for transport
from inside the sky crane you get a
better
idea of what it's like to transport a
heavy free swinging load
the rudder of the payload serves as a
wind vane
and helps to stabilize the damaged
skyraider in transit
finally we are over the lst and the
cargo at the end of the cable
is decked
back at quinon other deliveries by
flying crane are being made
in this case the fuselage of a uh-1d
helicopter is brought into position
and lowered onto a bed of old tires
where it will be checked over
later
returning to on k and the first air
cavalry division base
we find the day-to-day activities of the
outfit
much the same as before their arrival in
vietnam
the post office is still a kind of link
with the folks back home
and the barber shop is busy as usual
there's even thought given to the
question of reenlistment
despite the fighting here vietnam is an
exotic and interesting land
in typical american fashion the streets
and roads of the base
have been given stateside names and as
you can see
vehicular traffic is rather steady as
people scurry about carrying on the work
of the division
in the days recently before these films
were made
the area had been inundated with heavy
rainfall
and the roads were in bad condition
but the prime mission of the division is
to take the war to the enemy
on this combat assault helicopters of
the 229th aviation battalion
airlifted a battalion of first cav
troopers
into konak all aircraft in the lift
received enemy ground fire and an armed
chopper was brought in to strafe the
area
the heavily wooded terrain below makes
spotting the enemy difficult
down there the vietcong have begun
firing at us
and our gunners return the fire
it seems the snipers are located around
the edges of those openings
so the pilot drops down for a closer
look
at treetop level you can see pretty well
but the enemy stayed hidden
after the first attack for the choppers
had ended they returned to the base for
more
ordinance and refueling the full load of
rockets and ammo for the m60
has been expended in the effort to
eliminate the enemy snipers at the lz
evaluating these strikes is difficult
because
unlike fixed targets the vietcong
gorillas use the endless jungles of this
land
as a living screen behind which they
evade contact
and disappear with amazing swiftness
fragmentation weapons like these rockets
are one answer to the problem of
eliminating the vietcong snipers
once they are pinpointed
and so the refueling the re-arming
and the flying of these missions goes on
on a surveillance flight over the
division sector the
character of this central plateau
country unfolds below
the establishment of the division base
was accomplished only after hewing the
wilderness to meet the requirement
up ahead lies the valley land of plaku
province
besides its heavily wooded hills it is
largely an agricultural region
producing crops of sweet potatoes remote
from any of the major population
centers of south vietnam the area has
few roads in every sense this
is back country and the farmers who live
here
employ only the crudest methods of
cultivating the land
and harvesting their crops
the top of hong kong mountain
overlooking on k
pass offers radar cover for the entire
area
where the war is concerned this type of
terrain is to be found over much of
south vietnam
between the 15th parallel and the 17th
parallel
the northland of south vietnam
in this kind of country embracing
jungles and overgrown valleys without
roads
the air mobile striking force of the
first cav
is at its best here the ground combat
troops of the division
are deployed against the vietcong
swiftly and without regard for the
unfriendly terrain
below us the peaceful village of ahnkay
belies the continual feverish activity
of war
which is taking place at the airfield
just beyond
in an operation where so many types of
helicopters are constantly in use
the requirement for servicing and
support maintenance
is unusually high but the organization
of the air mobile division
is such that the maintenance support
element is prepared for this problem
a level maintenance can be carried out
in the field
if the job is relatively uncomplicated
and can be completed within four hours
bigger more complex repair jobs are
b level maintenance and are usually done
at the division base
within a 72 hour time limit if the
difficulty cannot be corrected in that
length of time the job is sent to rear
echelon
for sea level maintenance like
everything else used by this division
the work is sent to the rear by air
lifting it out
the sky cranes seen earlier are capable
of transporting
any aircraft used by the division
watching the crowded air space overhead
you understand
more readily the amount of aircraft
maintenance being done
as formations of assault helicopters
whirl away on their particular missions
other squadrons are returning other
armed helicopters take to the air
to provide fire support for the troop
carriers
then there are the recon helicopters
always shuttling back and forth
on one mission or another
the support command of the first cavalry
air mobile division
has a variety of assignments to carry
out one of the most
important is to deliver the divisions
artillery
with an air assault underway the gun
crew loads a 105 howitzer into a waiting
chinook
it will be flown to a strategic ground
position
where it can be used to support the
assault
ammunition for the field piece is
palletized
and with the aid of a cargo sling is
also airlifted along
unloading at the objective is
efficiently and quickly accomplished
by the highly trained gun crew
moments later the chinook with mission
accomplished
lifts off before the enemy spots it and
can start firing
on this mission a small truck was taken
along to assist in moving the gun into
its position
another phase of air mobility in vietnam
you